des chantiers au québec il y en a plein
les routes les ponts les maisons en
construction avec les grèves des
ingénieurs d'état et des travailleurs de
la construction
on a voulu connaître les conséquences
[Musique]
si on prend uniquement les travaux du
ministère des transports
il ya 100 chantiers qui ont été retardés
des chantiers qui en ce moment devrait
être en activité mais à cause de la
menace de grève
ils ont été remis à plus tard par contre
53 autres endroits où les travaux
étaient commencés et en ce moment ce
sont des chantiers paralysés
comme par exemple le pont dubuc à
saguenay les travaux sont suspendus
même chose pour le conte pierre laporte
à québec pour combler que la romaine sur
la côte-nord
hydro québec ne prévoit pas d'impact
significatif oui une grève pourrait
entraîner quelques jours de retard ça ne
devrait pas changer grand chose pour un
projet qui est échelonné sur plusieurs
années
la dernière grève en 2013 avait duré six
à dix jours selon les secteurs ayant eu
des impacts sur l'économie le pib du
québec avaient baissé de 0,2 pour cent
c'est un faible recul
si vous avez des travaux prévus chez
vous que vous faites construire votre
maison par exemple il se peut que vous
ouvriez face la grève mais que ce soit
pour des travaux privés ou d'un secteur
public la loi contrairement à d'autres
domaines
elle ne force pas les travailleurs à
débrayer c'est à chacun des sites et si
vous voulez qu'on vérifier autre chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]